LARRY P. ARNN: It's
in your choosing
that your character
is formed, which
gives you the right kind
of direction in your life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Choice and deliberation.
Give me an example of an
unwilling act that we do?
SPEAKER 2: Well, like
when I was younger,
and you had to
clean up-- your mom
made you clean up
your room, and you
didn't want to
clean up your room,
but you did it because
you were forced to.
LARRY P. ARNN: That is, by
the way, a perfect example.
Because the hard
choices typically
involve some element of duress.
So when you're a child, your
parents do that for you.
In the end, there really isn't
an option when you're not
of age, because you're a long
way from being mature enough
to take off and leave
them and might not
be able to make it
stick if you did.
What is the process by
which choices are produced?
SPEAKER 3: Is that what
we call deliberation?
LARRY P. ARNN: It is.
Explain that.
SPEAKER 3: So
deliberation, instead
of debating about what the
ends are of our actions,
deliberation is about selecting
the best means by which we
attain those ends.
LARRY P. ARNN: So deliberation
is not about ends.
Where do ends come from?
SPEAKER 4: Our nature.
LARRY P. ARNN: Our nature.
Our nature cultivated?
SPEAKER 5: It says wish.
So ends are wished for.
ANd depending on
your nature, you're
going to wish for
better or worse ends
because of what they desire.
So a good nature will desire
better ends than a bad nature.
LARRY P. ARNN: It's this demand
of leading a life of character,
an ethical life.
It's in your choosing that
your character is formed,
which gives you the right kind
of direction in your life.
We're about to see
when we separate
each act into its
component parts,
it's always made
up of two things--
what you want and an estimation
of the circumstances.
And what you want is
achieved, the right thing,
by practice and thought about
what the right way to live is,
and what the right
kind of person is,
and about what the
ultimate ends are.
And remember, you're making
these deliberations--
if they're the kind that are
meaningful in the shaping
of your character, you're
making them under pressure.
It means there are stakes.
It means that you
might get hurt or fail
to get some large benefit.
It means that you're
likely to be tired.
You have to decide, right
now, and you can never
be sure because you can
never be sure of the future.
You can never be sure of the
consequences what you do.
You have to make a guess.
And you get better
at that by trying it.
But the guessing part itself--
because what matters
the most-- what
is the thing, when you
make a choice, that matters
the most about whether it
tends to build virtue in you
or not-- what is that thing?
SPEAKER 6: Intention.
LARRY P. ARNN: Intention.
What do you want?
When you get older,
you'll figure this out.
The what you want part,
when you make a choice,
will be more important to
how you remember the choice,
and how you regard yourself,
and what specifically you chose
to do, and what the result was.
You ever crash a car?
SPEAKER 3: Yep.
LARRY P. ARNN: Any of the
girls ever crashed a car?
Yeah, see.
Don't we resent that, guys?
It doesn't seem fair, but it
does seem true, doesn't it?
I crashed them all the
time when I was a kid.
Why?
Because I didn't-- I never
crashed one bad, but--
and my dad was not a rich man.
I'd break his cars.
And why?
I was young and stupid,
inexperienced, you see.
So just remember, even in this
formative time in your life,
what you see is the thing
that has to be got right.
And if you get used to that,
you'll get better and better
at the job of seeking it.
That's what changes
your character.
That's what shapes it, and forms
it, and makes you what you are.
I'm Larry Arnn, president
of Hillsdale College.
You will find, if you look
at our online courses,
that they cover the whole
range of human learning,
all the high and fundamental
things everyone needs to know.
They are free because
we have always
wished to provide sound
learning to anyone
who wishes to have it.